there's one thing my kids could do that
I would not love and support so what do
you think about the current president
that we have
I actually am inspired by what has
happened in this country have you been
following the whole Alex Jones the
controversy what some argue is a
dangerous person would you say initially
when you came out you were trolling a
lot more according to mila kunis i
invented trolling trolling did not exist
before Perez Hilton so look a lot of
people start blogs a lot of people start
throwing websites and you go and log in
to get the data understanding so my gosh
today 28 people are gone oh my goodness
City 273 they love this new article I
had a big hit 1000 people came on my
website today the man sitting next to me
8 plus million hits single day 2 Perez
Hilton not calm Hollywood bad boy with
that being said Paris Hilton thank you
for making the time to spend some time
with us here yes and it's a special
place we're at we're on this stage this
is a main stage of Chippendales right so
this is unique I've been here in Vegas
for over 3 weeks now the special
celebrity host here at Chippendales and
I've been having the best time really
I've been doing a lot of acting and
we're just performing lately which is
kind of going back to what I originally
wanted to do in the 90s I'm dating
myself I went to college and I studied
acting and then I got sidetracked with
my little hobby that turned into a
full-fledged career that allowed me to
support not just myself but also my
family and recently I've been on TV
shows auditioning and I got this great
opportunity to come out to Vegas which I
love and my mom loves and my kids have
been enjoying and it's been great you've
had a lot of great stories that come out
and there's been a lot of controversy
there's people that love you there's
people that H I mean you got the bad you
got the whole thing going on right which
is what kind of needs to be when
somebody really gets good at what they
do who were you in high school though if
I went to high school with you more in
10th grade together we're in math
we're taking history class who was Paris
Hilton in high school I went to an
all-boy Jesuit School in Miami I almost
did well without even trying graduated
top ten in my class in high school and I
went to NYU on a full scholarship so
were you always curious in other
people's stories even when you were in
high school like was there always a
curiosity oh did you see what happened
over there what was there always there
how early did that start for you I'll
tribute most of my success to my
upbringing in that I grew up in a Latino
households where gossiping wasn't a bad
thing
in fact she smeared the cheese me it it
was a good thing like you wanted to be
in the know everybody did it and my mom
was the biggest cheese samosa in the
neighborhood she knew everything about
everybody but the neighborhood on the
street about my family and about
celebrities you know she would get her
spanish-language celebrity weekly
magazines so I picked up a lot of that
from her and also just the Cuban work
ethic you know both of my parents fled a
communist regime oppression and came to
this country with nothing and had to
build something out of that and they
instilled in me just the importance of
not just even working hard but working
very hard having to work harder than
everybody else that's why I set my bar
really high so that if I don't even
achieve it it's still higher than most
and you had that from the bit like you
knew this is what space you're gonna be
in and I also knew I was different from
everybody else Miami in the 90s was very
different than it is now I would say
back then it wasn't very accepting or
tolerant of different people not
necessarily even just gay people like if
you were growing up in Miami in the 90s
and you told your parents I want to be a
sculptor they'd be like oh you're not
gonna be a sculptor you need to be a
doctor or a lawyer or an engineer which
is what everybody who went to my
all-boys Jesuit school did you were a
doctor or a lawyer an engineer you have
three kids right and you said I'm hoping
my sons are straight and not gay
because it's in easier life yeah I think
you said that right what do you what did
you mean by that
just the same way I hope that my
daughters aren't fat
I grew up fat I still carried that
baggage it was so hard for me being fat
even after I grew up all my 20s like
yo-yoing and having constant issues with
my body and my weight clearly I will
love and accept my children no matter
well that's not true there's one thing
my kids could do that I would not love
and support they could do anything else
and I would love and support them dot
that dot so long as they're not lazy I
will not tolerate lazy children you
don't have to be in all a student but I
have to know that you're putting in the
effort so if you're getting C's but
working your butt off okay you worked
really hard and that's what you could do
but I'm not gonna sit back and be like
oh it's okay you don't have to try by
the way that's a very interesting
dynamic that when they say less than
I've learned in life in this day and age
you might luck your way into success you
know there are a lot of instances
because of social media of these
personalities who do nothing and then
overnight they have two million
followers on Instagram however you don't
even need Talent but you will not
sustain success if you're lazy
I absolutely agree with you so would you
say you are a 100% capitalist when it
comes down to the economy because I know
your family left to Cuba communism so
you would say you hundred percent
believe in capitalism absolutely of
course I mean but I also personally give
back and I don't even like to put labels
on myself like I am an open-minded
person and very liberal but in many ways
I'm also very conservative I want to
give back I also want low taxes I want
the best of both worlds at least you're
open about it yeah great oh you know cuz
sometimes but I also do believe in
giving back you know like let's tax
alcohol let's tax cigarettes let's tax
gaming the lotto
let's find creative ways do we real
need to spend thankfully that was
canceled like 20 million dollars on a
military parade let's be smart with how
we are spending our money wow so do you
actually follow politics as well or no
do you stay away from now not go to that
political conversations I've always been
in you know interested and discussing
what's happening in our country I don't
call my website an entertainment news
site I call it a pop culture site and to
me politics social issues silly cat
videos all of that falls under the
umbrella of pop culture so what do you
think about the current president that
we have any other Presidente Karen
McDougal story or a stormy Daniels story
would be done but it doesn't seem like
it does anything with this with Donna
Johnson what is so different about him
that makes him an anomaly I have come
through the storm does he mention stormy
Daniels and I actually am inspired by
what has happened in this country in
that I've never experienced a president
like him before people older than me
lived through Richard Nixon and maybe he
was somewhat comparable but it's just
nice to know you know what we could have
the most ill-equipped person in the
White House and the world is not going
to stop spinning the country hasn't
exploded or imploded yet thankfully
clearly I'm not happy with everything
but now there's less than two years left
almost less than two it I've already
jumped into next year you don't think
he's getting reelected at all I can't
think past 2020 right now and I know I
voted in the last election I don't think
he will get reelected just because I
know there were so many Republicans who
voted for him just because they hated
Hillary Clinton that much and they knew
he was awful but they had convinced
themselves that she was worse for some
reason so who do you think's coming up
that's not going to be a war here hey
anybody okay anybody you don't even need
experience I mean there's actually a lot
of viable options to me you know
love Elizabeth Warren a Cory Booker not
a Bernie Sanders I think he's too old
he's also not a Democrat and I'm also
not a socialist you're absolutely not a
sectionals so what do you think about
the Democratic Party right now the
challenge you're going through where
they feel like they're being pulled to
the left cuz can happen a Hillary if
Mike Bloomberg runs for president in
2020 which he could have run this last
cycle but he didn't want to hurt Hillary
Clinton's chances of winning
he ended up speaking at the DNC the
Democratic National Convention I would
seriously consider voting for Mike
Bloomberg and he used to be a Republican
you know I'm very open-minded I
acknowledge that there are some amazing
Republicans out there I can name a ton
of them one of my favorite politicians a
real sensible smart person Ilyana Ross
laitanan it also helps when people have
those and their families that aren't the
same as them so if you're a Republican
in Congress but your son or daughter is
a Democrat or your son or daughter is
gay or your son or daughter married a
Muslim person then if you're that
Republican that opens your mind
Ilyana Ross Layton has a transgender
child so she's a very liberal Republican
people like Megan McCain even John
McCain people like Anna Navarro
I don't think all Republicans are bad I
just think Trump Republicans are bad and
I'm not afraid to say that like the
people that will support him no matter
what that troubles me well I have a
problem with anybody that's no matter
what any candidate or middle critical
Hillary Clinton I can be critical of
anybody like if somebody wants to go as
a centrist independent candidate you
know some people might think oh the
Republican Party's gone to trump and the
Democratic Party's gone to socialists so
I'm gonna go with this guy who's
speaking to me when you typically go too
far left and then you go too far right
then you're typically going to want
somebody in the middle so that could
actually take place next year that'd be
very interesting somebody in the middle
makes a run and now experience is made
it know that's the campaign yeah looking
for president with no experience need
I mean I honestly think and almost maybe
I won't say anybody but like ninety-nine
out of a hundred people could do a
better job than Donald Trump when you
were coming up and I know obviously
right now a lot of people look at oh boy
it's either TMZ or it's you and the
stories are coming out who's gonna bring
it out but what was the first break what
was the first story that popped them
people said wow what is this coming from
how did that happen for you back in 2004
when I started it was the wild wild west
of the internet it was so new and I
didn't know what I was doing I stirred
it off blogging as a hobby not thinking
anybody was reading my site like Oh
nobody's reading this I was doing things
then that I don't do now because I know
better not to do them now so the first
thing that really got everybody's
attention was well first of all I mixed
named Brad and Angelina Brangelina
that was a Perez Hilton term and then I
posted the first photos of them together
as a couple I out scooped everybody and
how I got those photos was I posted them
illegally I didn't pay for them there
was a big bidding war for these photos
and now the photo agencies don't even
operate this way anymore the photo
agency sent the photos to all the
celebrity magazines in the UK and in the
US and asking for the highest bidder in
each territory and I was friendly with
an editor at one of the UK magazines
whose magazine got outbid so they were
not gonna run the photos so they leaked
me the photos and because print wasn't
coming out for a few more days I posted
them before they went to print and I
posted the first photos of red print
Angelina Jolie anywhere and there was so
much traffic to my website that it
crashed people were so interested in
like oh my god it's true they're really
dated they're together on the beach that
was the spring of 2005 thirteen years
ago so you said you got a contact from
UK but you're here so how did you become
so good at your sources being willing to
share like what is in return it's not
like you're a billionaire and you're CNN
yours and I'll give you a million bucks
I'll give you hundred grand I well how
did you do that because that's what's
difficult for other sites pay for
information I never
but it helped that I was living in Los
Angeles and I had been there a few years
already so I knew a lot of people
starting off and my friends would just
tell me things and then my readers would
tell me things too and back then I was a
lot more liberal with what I would post
to like a random reader would email me I
saw this happened and I would in fact
check it back then now I don't do that
anymore
now I know better now I don't want to
get sued I'm very familiar with the law
now I operated differently than I do now
and I was a kid
now I'm the 40 year old father of three
and I know better and when you know
better you do better how do you manage
let's just like Lady Gaga you want Lady
Gaga to good relationship together a
friendship there was a little bit of
falling out you know good and bad you
and I are friends we've spent time
together I consider your friend we're
Texan we're going back and forward
you're talking to me but you have a
story on you yeah on me I would run it
you would run it absolutely I wouldn't
even call you anymore maybe in the past
now I don't even try to have celebrity
friends for example Katy Perry I was
also really I thought I was I was really
good friends with Katy Perry when she
was nobody and I was already known I
first met her in 2007 I started in 2004
by 2007 you know I had been on a ton of
TV shows I had a series of specials on
vh1 I co-hosted MTV New Year's Eve I had
been profiled in GQ Rolling Stone people
knew me very well
nobody knew Katy Perry and then I was a
big champion supporter of hers and then
she became a really big star and things
just got awkward and difficult she
almost became too big of a star to be my
friend if that made sense did that
create resentment with you were you kind
of like we understood it I was happy for
her when the guys a turning point for
you yeah her and then Gaga and then
other people like just realizing that I
don't want to have some luck about it so
you made a distinction yes and I am NOT
your friend this is my what you think I
had friends but then I I just grew up
and I realized underneath it all it's an
unequal relationship in the case of
somebody like Lady Gaga
it may have started off them using me or
and then it might have
to me using them and then it might have
gone back and forth but there was always
and will always be some element of using
each other which I don't think a normal
non celebrity friendship has have you
been following the whole Alex Jones the
controversy I how do you think about
that you think it's right that these
guys got together and they did what they
did Alex Jones is this ultra right-wing
what some argue is a dangerous person
conspiracy theorist he's been banned
from a lot of private companies so
privately owned organizations saying he
violates their Terms of Use okay that's
their choice personally I would not have
banned him what I would have done is
make his material not come up in
searches if he's on YouTube for example
and he's talking about Donald Trump if I
search Donald Trump on YouTube I don't
want to see anything from Alex Jones
show up on a search she'll feel to him
oh yeah the only way people should be
able to see them if they're subscribed
to him so he should still be able to
reach his subscribers but not show up
and search I think but I don't think he
should be banned you don't think it
should be me no I don't agree with what
he's saying but I will defend his right
to say it even on privately owned
platforms you know the government can
prosecute him for saying stupid wrong
things they can for inciting violence
they say that they have the right to ban
him because it's a private enterprise I
have the right to ban any customer that
I want I don't have to accept you they
clearly have their Terms of Service and
they could point say oh he violated this
he fighted that he violated that but
like I said I I don't support banning
him you've been able to take your blog
from what it was to now tens of millions
of people have visited they read your
stuff on a daily basis do what kept you
going they got you to worry about today
not overthinking things don't overthink
things just do I don't have time to sit
and stew I just go I just do whatever
interests me whatever I think will be
fun whatever I think people want to see
or
here whatever I observe is working for
other people or in other ways like I've
made YouTube a big priority or you're on
YouTube of my family channel is growing
at 15% a month you know I'm just so
proud that everything went off without a
hitch today with Perez Hilton 2.0 it'd
been a long time coming I should have
done a major redesign and a revamp a
long time ago but I want to do this so I
did it and I'm thankful I did and
traffic has been up majorly today so
that's a good thing and I think it will
continue to go ups fast it's clean and
it just feels current like my old
website had not been updated in forever
it's never too late to change course
it's never too late to try something new
to try something different you know I
look at somebody like a Joan Rivers as
an ultimate inspiration for me because
she suffered a lot of setbacks had an
incredible career was working literally
until the week she died I could learn so
much from her and I have and you know
I've been around long enough to have
made a bunch of mistakes and for a while
there I was going through the know phase
which is a strategy that a lot of people
apply but now I'm going through my yes
phase and not only yes my thing is not
just to say yes to a lot but to say yes
and yes I'll do that and how what's the
smartest way to do that how can I turn
this one opportunity into an even bigger
opportunity how can I do that and have
it not disrupt my life like really being
smart about the yeses and and turning
yes into more yes so yes and yeah it's
pretty powerful you know you can't get
lazy what excites me is just continuing
to have a long career and continuing to
show people who I really am I don't see
the provoking is gonna go away anytime
soon I think provoke I love titillating
but you can do that in a way that's not
mean or cruel
I love stirring the pot I'm super
transparent
what would you say initially when you
came out you were you were you were
trolling a lot more yeah I still troll I
love to troll but you can and you can
trol in an on main way there's tons of
ways you control without being a nasty
mean troll although mila kunis recently
said in an interview that i invented
trolling so I will take that I I keep I
keep waiting for somebody to add that to
my Wikipedia and nobody has according to
Mila Kunis I invented trolling trolling
did not exist before Perez Hilton title
of the video the inventor of trolling
take a final thought you know we
obviously we our audience they're
entrepreneurs they're business people
sure younger they're trying to go out
there and do something big for
themselves what are some thoughts you
have for them one of my favorite things
to tell young people when I go speak at
colleges or high schools a lot of
business people and entrepreneurs are
hung up on their the idea everybody
thinks they have the most brilliant
genius idea and then I tell young people
and you know ideas are not special you
are special and then they roll their
eyes and they're like oh no that's BS
because I could come up with something
nobody's ever thought of before you were
living in Las Vegas and somebody in
Australia randomly may have come up with
the exact same brilliant never before
done idea Wow what are the odds of that
but you know what it's not about the
idea it's about you what you bring to
the table how you execute the idea so
what I'm getting at is you are special
so whenever you can find what is inside
of you that's different and special and
fine-tune it and share it with the world
success will come a lot quicker and that
becomes a great idea because you are a
great idea exactly very interesting I
like that so there you have it again
anything you took away from this comment
below if you have any thoughts you want
to share with them you can tweet what's
your Twitter handle by the way is it we
have to the Perez Hilton is for me
personally and then Perez Hilton is for
the website do either one of them will
put one of them will put the Perez
Hilton right send a tweet to him and
again if you haven't subscribed do so
thanks for watching everybody Perez
thank you so much for joining thank you
take care bye bye